[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
taking a look at some of the creatures
of the magical world
however we're not just going to be
looking at any old creatures
we're going to be honing in on the
darkest fowlest creatures
to inhabit the wizarding world
fortunately for every dark creature
there seems to be a healthy number of
friendly counterparts
but that certainly doesn't mean that the
magical world is devoid of evil
you guys seem to really enjoy these
ranking videos but just remember
this is purely my opinion and i implore
you all to comment your own lists
down below without further ado please
enjoy the 10
darkest creatures in the wizarding world
number 10
basilisks if you've seen red the chamber
of secrets then you'll know
what basilisks are enormous serpentine
creatures
that were originally created by a dark
wizard by the name
of herpo the fowl of the many fearsome
beasts and monsters that roam our land
there is none more curious or more
deadly than the basilisk
known also as the king of serpents this
snake which may reach gigantic size
and live many hundreds of years is born
from a chicken's egg
hatched beneath a toad its methods of
killing are most wondrous
for aside from its deadly and venomous
fangs the basilisk has a murderous stare
and all who are fixed with the beam of
its eye shall suffer
instant death spiders flee before the
basilisk
for it is their mortal enemy and the
basilisk flees only
from the crowing of the rooster which is
fatal to it
basilisks are gigantic powerful and
immune to a lot of magic
not only that but they possess gigantic
fangs protective scales
and a gaze that can kill you instantly
number nine
hags hags are essentially warty evil
looking witches
and witches are often confused with hags
in muggle literature
the appearance of a hag is what one
might imagine when trying to consider
the appearance of a witch
but for those who know of the magical
world they know that witches can
actually be
very beautiful it's also worth
mentioning that the level of magic the
tags possess
is less than that of a normal witch we
first hear of the term hag
in the philosopher's stone when hagrid
mentions that queerness quirrell
had a run-in with one they say quirrell
met vampires in the black forest
and there was a nasty bit of trouble
with a hag according to quentin trimble
author of the dark forces a guide to
self-protection
hags can be defined as follows the hag
is a child eating creature of human
appearance
though likely to have more warts than
the average witch
in addition to being strikingly ugly and
possessing only four toes on each foot
the hank is doubly scary because it just
so happens to have a taste for human
flesh
specifically the flesh of children hags
made it onto this list
not because they are particularly
powerful but because there really isn't
anything
pure about them their entire life is
devoted to
eating children and they purportedly
even advertise themselves
as babysitters creepy number eight
banshees i know that when i see or hear
banshee
i think of gilderoy lockhart the
catalyst for this of course being his
made-up stories
surrounding his besting of various
powerful magical creatures
lockhart's book break with the banshee
outlines his defeat of the bandin benshi
a powerful banshee that terrorized the
wizarding world
i didn't get rid of the band and banshee
by smiling at her
lockhart famously stated we know now
that lockhart's tale was fabricated
taking credit for the accomplishment of
another witch but in truth
banshees do exist and they are very
dangerous dark creatures
banshees are dark malevolent spirits
native to scotland and ireland
that assume the form of skeletal looking
women with
green skin and black hair banshees are
particularly dangerous
as they are able to produce a
high-pitched scream that can prove fatal
to the ears
like hags their existence is entirely
wicked
and there isn't a good bone that exists
in their bodies
the best defense against a banshee is a
simple laughing potion
number 7. gorgonz the best way to have
people clue in to what exactly a gorgon
is
is to mention the most famous gorgon
from mythology
medusa medusa was a woman in greek
mythology
whose beauty was often compared to the
beautiful goddess athena
this outraged athena and so she decided
to curse medusa
making her ugly and turning her hair
into snakes
from this point onward whenever anyone
looked directly at medusa
it would be turned to stone medusa and
her two sisters were the original
gorgons
off topic for a second if you want to
learn more about mythology
check out the link for my mythology
channel in the pinned comment
moving on it just so happens that
gorgons also exist in the harry potter
universe and they are mentioned in
miranda goshawks the rime of gormless
morgan
the gorgon was fearsome and clever two
things that paul morgan was never
by staring alone she could turn men to
stone so they'd have to be statues
forever
number six zombies that's right the
harry potter universe doesn't exclude
zombies and i'm not talking about in
fairy
i'm talking about exactly the type of
zombies that you're thinking of
zombies first pop up in a 1913 defense
against a dark arts lesson
in which a student's pocket turns in to
a zombie they were also mentioned in the
philosopher's stone
as quirrell mentions that his turban was
a gift from an african prince
for getting rid of a zombie they are
also mentioned in quentin trimbles
the dark forces a guide to
self-protection
he had this to say the zombie dwells
only in the southern part of america
it is an example like the vampire of the
living dead
and may be recognized by its grayish
color and its rotten smell
zombies are of course creatures that
originated in haitian
folklore they are basically resurrected
and reanimated
human corpses that feed on flesh number
five
bogats bogats are essentially
manifestations of our deepest
darkest fears they are immortal
shape-shifting
non-beings that transform into whatever
you fear most
no one knows what a boggart looks like
by itself because it will transform
as soon as you encounter it when buggers
aren't scaring people
they can usually be found rustling
around in confined spaces
or lurking around dark corners similar
to poltergeists which have an affinity
for mischief
think peeves and dementors which thrive
on darkness and depression
pockets are paired with fear one of the
most interesting things about pockets
is that when they transform into
something they can replicate its
abilities
i.e when a blogger transforms into a
dementor it's able to do
all the horrible things that a dementor
can it's worth mentioning
however that the boggart's abilities
will be very suppressed
compared to the original creature or
being number four
obscurus an obscurial is someone who
carries an obscurus
a dark manifestation of repressed energy
they are parasitic in nature
and that they are deeply attached to the
host an obscurus is most commonly
created
when a troubled child consciously
attempts to repress their magical
abilities
or were forced to do so through physical
or psychological abuse
newt scamander puts it perfectly before
wizard went underground
when we were still being hunted by
muggles young witches and wizards
sometimes tried to suppress their magic
to avoid persecution
so instead of learning to harness or to
control their powers
they developed what was called an
obscurus the obscurus
is easily one of the darkest creatures
or parasites in the wizarding world
as it is created entirely out of
negative energy
number three lethal folds fantastic
beasts and where to find them
describes lethal folds perfectly the
lethal fold resembles a black cloak
roughly half an inch thick and appears
slightly thicker
if the creature has recently digested a
victim it glides along surfaces
in an unknown form of locomotion in
search of its prey
humans it attacks at night and the
target is asleep by suffocating and then
digesting it
lethal folds are quite similar to
dementors and can even be watered off
with expecto patronum
the etymology behind the name lethal
fold is quite sinister
as lethal fold comes from two roots
lethal
variation of lithium which is latin for
death
annihilation and ruin as well as fold
which likely alludes to the creature's
cloaked appearance
the lethal fold is a truly dangerous
magical beast that's extremely
aggressive
violent and even carnivorous number two
inferi the inferi are dark corpses that
have been brought back to life
reanimated by a dark wizard's curse
harry and dumbledore first encounter
inferi in the cave
where they inhabit a lake separating the
entrance of the cave
from the horcrux inside according to
pottermore
after the invaria have been reanimated
they become a grisly puppet
and may be used as an expendable servant
by the dark wizard in question
the most obvious sign that one is facing
in nefarious rather than a living human
are the white and cloudy eyes nothing
screams dark creature
like a corpse that has been magically
brought back to life
voldemort amassed an army of inferi most
likely from the corpses of witches
wizards that he killed himself they are
the undead
and they exist solely to commit
atrocities
number one dementors i'm sure you saw
this one coming
but to be honest i'd be hard-pressed to
put any of the others above dementors
because dementors just are the darkest
dementors are cloaked creatures that are
three meters tall
with dark gray scabby skin dementors are
foul creatures
that represent unhappiness and despair
they were created by rowling as a way of
personifying all of the negative aspects
of depression
and there basically isn't even an inch
of purity in a dementor
dementors are among the foulest
creatures that walk this earth
they infest the darkest filthiest places
they glory and decay
and despair they drain peace hope and
happiness out of the air around them
even muggles feel their presence though
they can't see them get too near a
dementor
and every good feeling every happy
memory will be sucked out of you
and there you have it that concludes my
list of the top 10
darkest creatures honorable mentions go
out to acromantulas
grindelos rugarus vampires and
werewolves
what are your top ten let me know in the
comment section
below until next time it is the unknown
we fear when we look upon death and
darkness
nothing more
you